welcome back to new rock stars this is
the bite size question all right phillip
uh we have a couple bite size questions
first when loki and thor get knocked to
the car in the bifrost by hella loki
says he got there
weeks before thor four so is there a
bifrost time travel
and is it connected to the tesseract and
loki's series time variance authority
for miles smiles
this was a really interesting question
to research too so the bi-frost
is traveling across space and time in a
literal way
but actually it's not traveling through
time in a like time-bending way
it did kind of seem like that in that
moment but what actually is happening
is it's not about the bifrost at all
it's about zakar
it's about where loki has gone sakar has
weird time abilities of some sort it
seems to exist in some sort of bubble or
something
so the grand master says it pretty
clearly says
i would be considered billions of years
old we talked about him earlier he's
this ancient but on sakaar he doesn't
seem so
and it's as if he doesn't continue to
age on sakhar
valkyrie has also been there for 200
years and you know
theoretically she hasn't aged i mean she
still looked good because thompson
so loki uh has thinks he's been there
for
two weeks or so he theoretically has
inside of sakaar
it does have that that feel of uh if you
remember an interstellar the closer they
got to the black hole oh yeah there was
uh time distortion yeah the double venus
is right over there so it's yeah
double anus
now here's a really interesting thing
though you kind of spun off a little
theory here that i was thinking
hulk has been there as the champion
for some amount of time we interpreted
it after he left earth on that ship
that you know he ends up on sakaar and
then over that time you know he whatever
he becomes a champion
but he actually could have been there
for decades for all we know
which would make a lot of sense for
about two things one that he
is the level of champion that he is
everybody is nuts everybody knows him
everybody has
hulk merch on uh but it could be this
has
been their guy for for decades hundreds
of years who knows how long
but also it could explain why there's
this sudden
extreme rift between hulk and bruce
banner where when bruce banner finally
comes back out
hulk has actually not just been the
front man of the body
for weeks or months it could have been
years that hulk has been thriving
you know doing some other stuff that
hulk doesn't normally get to do
and then he got forced back in so maybe
that is partially also why
oh now you want me to come out again
just to fight this guy meanwhile i just
spent you know 100 years uh yeah
pillaging
and villaging from chris parish
he wants to know how much would cap have
to drink to get legally drunk
it reminds us how in the first avenger
cap says it's hard to get drunk
because of his super metabolism i'm
super excited to answer this question
because it actually has
an answer that we can get and i love
when we have definitive answers
so cap drunk you said legally drunk i'm
gonna get back to that
okay but can cap even get drunk okay our
bodies metabolize
you and me we metabolize alcohol at
percent per hour so if you think of your
blood alcohol rate you just can subtract
0.016
uh every hour and that's how how fast
you start coming back from it
with your liver metabolism but we
actually have his metabolism rate
because peggy tells us in that scene
his metabolism is four times faster than
the average person
so his is .064 per hour
now you can already see the legal limit
is 0.08
so he's almost doing that whole thing in
an hour pretty quickly but it also isn't
insane
it's not like he he absolutely can't get
drunk but
it's hard most people perceive drunken
feelings at point one two percent
which is significantly higher than the
legal limit for driving which is why
if you feel drunk you very much yes sit
down
in a car turn the keys nope drive into a
school
but before i continue i want to thank
our friends at hunt a killer for
sponsoring this episode
so folks it is winter you're still stuck
at home and if you're bored out of your
gourd hunter killer is here
to wipe away those winter blues and
replace them with some immersive horror
fun
so hunter killer has made thousands of
fans with their immersive game it's kind
of like a monthly true crime
escape room delivered to your door
haunted killer horror is their new
scarier game it's set
in the blair witch universe i still have
nightmares about the original blair
witch movie
a pivotal viewing experience for young
eric and the reason i will never go to
any woods
second yosemite i know those trees are
alive and will
bend five of them together into the
blair witch symbol so each month hunter
killer horror
sends you a new package of clues of
ciphers and documents to get you closer
to the truth
oh my god so here are the materials you
get like oh a little tooth necklace
you get uh liam kent's journal in here
and he has drawn pictures
an incident report uh i
am freaked out just from opening this
already uh but also very excited i just
really
love the attention to detail they're
putting into the materials in this
package and that extends to
creating the real social media accounts
for characters and other immersive
details it just really adds to feeling
like you
are the main character of this creepy
detective story play along with your
family or put together a zoom call with
friends to get in
on that scary solvent action it's also
designed so that you can play it by
yourself
which i am way too much of a scaredy cat
to attempt
so how do you get in on this action well
you just go to huntakiller.com
rockstars and use the code rockstars for
off your first box again make sure to
use the code rockstars for a 20
discount can you survive the curse of
the blair witch i don't think i will
but you can the issue here isn't that
whether or not he can get drunk
it's he has to outpace his own
metabolism
in order to feel it so he has to drink
faster than he burns it
and the thing is you might think well
maybe he his absorption rate we can't
know that it might be faster because
he's superhuman
i don't i'm gonna give him the
absorption rate of the normal man
because if he
had super fast absorption he would die
from poison like really quickly it could
be very easy to kill him
so let's assume he absorbs as fast as we
do he just burns it a lot faster
so that means we can use chris evans
body stats which i got
all of them yeah and some of them will
surprise you and some of them will
impress you and some of them
will make doctors hate you you not him
our
articles are written about this body
chris evans body i measured it i
got these stats to figure out how
quickly alcohol hits
his blood and then i used captain
america's metabolism rate for how
quickly it would burn it away
so if he does three shots per hour
his not only will he not get drunk he
won't even
get anything he will be burning it
faster than he's taking it in
it's only at four shots per hour that he
even starts to increase his blood
alcohol level but literally
anything 0.001 right
it would take him four shots an hour to
even start the climb yeah
so that's very far from drunk so for him
to feel drunk
he has to do this is my best advice
captain america in order for you to ever
feel drunk
you're gonna need to do right away as
soon as you start drinking
nine shots of liquor out of the gate
then
uh that's at the top of the hour by the
end of the hour
you will feel drunk for nine minutes
nine glorious minutes where anything
goes
anything can be yours any surface is a
road no stop is suggesting that people
do that okay
uh and on that tenth minute he will no
longer feel drunk
so in order to stay drunk if you're
trying to have a night of it it's a
birthday
then you have to keep doing another shot
about every 10 minutes once so you start
with the nine shots
just to get up there and now you've
outpaced enough that you'll feel drunk
and then every ten minutes you have to
do one more shot
so that's a nightmare and he's never
gonna do that some i have two other tips
as guardian beer it exists in your
reality it thor has
claimed that it's much better than ours
i'm sure if it can make a nice guardian
drunk you should drink that
or technically according to my math
jessica jones also has a right
a whole bottle at a time that they
actually can keep up with that's
expensive just pour it up your butthole
pour it in the booty hole up your
butthole up
yeah i'm not tipping upside down this
body don't tip you gotta put it in there
and then you gotta blow because you need
a vacuum effect
yeah just gotta reverse the polarity of
my digestive system
and then when i this is gonna work hold
on
you have to suck it like and then go and
blow it
yeah exactly see and that worked
and i'm real drunk oh man
i'm disgusting our next question
from james jones asks if the tesseract
melted through the metal of an advanced
hydra
aircraft how was the happy days lunch
box able to hold it good question
actually i've seen this one before and a
lot of people think it's a plot hole
i actually identified a trend of when
the tesseract
burns through things so through the
hydra ship but
also it burns nick fury's hand once you
gotta remember the tesseract
is a container for a infinity stone
that's right it is not the infinity
stone itself
and even though there's kind of some
special properties there where it has
some sentience and that's why it
rejected red skull
it doesn't actually do this superheating
thing just on its own
it has to have recently been used so if
you look at the two times that it has
melted or burned someone
it's because it was in use on the space
stone level
but you can think of the tesseract as
almost like um paper towels holding a
baking pan of brownies
it's fine on the way into the oven it
gonna hurt on the way out
oh the paper towels are still
radioactive yes that's exactly what i
meant i saw chernobyl uh all right and
our third bite size question uh make
sure to follow us
at uh at eavos at philadelene on social
media follow new rockstar is that new
rockstar i'm mad at you
i know yeah yeah i'm on your side
um and you can get audio versions of
this podcast early if you
just follow new rockstar's big question
wherever you get your podcast
and uh yeah we'll see you next week make
sure to hit us up with your big
questions using the hashtag big question
just real quick also share the show with
your friends i feel like it's a good
entry point into new rockstars so if
your friend is kind of nerdy and trying
to find a way in
give them an all big question link see
ya
see you next week bye
[Music]
you